i knew i wanted i was only going to play
in dallas
la or new york i was willing to give up
some ends on the front end because i
know i'll make it back up
from marketing i thought this whole time
cause you were a cowboy fan yo i'm so
disappointed my dad was a big cowboy
yeah yeah but but no i did we were
cowboy fans we all be huge cowboy fans
but but i knew i i i was going to go to
dallas and then jimmy jimmy came to me
jimmy johnson he said michael
he said i understand what you're doing i
can appreciate he says but dallas is
going to draft you he said none of them
damn shenanigans with that i said no
coach that's how i'm going to play for
dallas this is good it's a cool story
play for dallas he i said why would you
think i would do he said i'm just
telling you he said i'm telling you
right now because
i got an oil buddy friend of mine who's
about the dallas cowboys about to buy
the dallas cowboys and they're crazy
i'll be joining you next year oh so
you knew was gonna happen
i knew he was coming oh
[Music]
bill and jerry bought the team the next
year and brought in jimmy wow and you've
been playing for jimmy
yeah at the u yeah
oh my god dawg a couple weeks ago when
they gave him his super bowl hall of
fame jimmy jimmy johnson yeah at
cowboys stadium yeah
my god man hey listen
i was right in back of him he was right
there dressed in the crowd i had just
seen jimmy at the hall of fame
you know he just got in hall and he was
happy and i see it happen
and when i saw him i never see him this
happy in my life and i just started
crying and crying and crying i get
emotions to talk about now because i sat
there and looked at him man like damn
look at all of this and the people were
going crazy and i thought about the
whole journey and all that we've done
together and i was like man all of this
could have been gone if he wasn't the
great man that he is cause i got into
on my first day in college
i heard about this i mean i'm swinging
and whipping people's ass
i just got there and and they were
playing with freshman on the table on
the the
she would take whatever they had around
the house and whoever what she was clean
who she would clean with whatever food
they would give her and she would put it
all in a party call it a casserole we
don't even know what it was but now i
have a training table all this food and
they were making the freshman's weight i
was like man i ain't wait man they come
here to play man i gotta i gotta make
some money now
so it's so so so this big lineman kept
trying to make me wait make me wait and
i did i did the first couple times and
then and then he tried to go and order
the same damn steak i wanted man i
cracked his head with that trick
they took me after my first day they
took me to jimmy's office and i walked
there
and
jimmy said mike
he said son you just got here so
can't be fighting our teammates so yeah
we can't do it yeah and i'm thinking
he's about to send me home man i just
got up out of that damn ghetto
[Laughter]
but he did he said you're a young man
i'm not going to say i'm not going to
suspend you he said i'm going to i'm
going to take it up with my with my
senior because he should have known
better not to let it get to that
situation so i was just thinking about
all the time that i had screwed up that
first year that wasn't the only fight
that went on fire i got in another fight
a week and a half later in in the in the
weight room yeah with linebacker he
pushes me because we're changing the
music freshman's was supposed to lift
and we're lifting freshman's
then they come in early and they change
the music hey man still the freshman out
we got 10 more minutes that's it for the
freshman
we're not doing that i'm going to twist
it back
and then they come and switch
dude i said we got eight more minutes
you just killed two of them but we're
gonna take our eight minutes and i
switched it back and then he pushes me
okay okay and he's getting between us
coach comes right down calls us upstairs
approving me with our team meeting we
know who dick
[Laughter]
jimmy said i want both michael
i want you and this come down in the
middle of this right now and shake hands
and i was still on sting dawg
please i could totally joke man i ain't
with this i ain't here for this man i
gotta make some money i get my family
like that hell man
and a whole while i'm walking down there
just shake his hand
just
just shake his hand and it is over
and closer and closer i got the harder
harder i got and as i got close to him
i held out the left hand oh he just
held out her left hand and i held him
he was shaking
oh you okay yeah
and then knocked him out broke his jaw
and everything wow
jimmy called me i said i'm definitely
getting caught i'm definitely going home
and he called me off the first thing he
said he's cause he's a big big boxer fan
he's gonna bring all the big boxers over
to talk to us yeah he looks at me said
son
have you ever thought about boxing
you know so what i was thinking about
when he was getting his ring and i saw
him so happy and all the moments and all
the things we won national championship
we won super bowl man we lived the life
man and i said oh my god all of it i
could have missed it all if he had to
just sit my rude ass back home none of
it would have happened and i just
couldn't stop crying because thanking
them for for just just believing in me
until i got through that rough time so
obviously he sees great talent in you
that's why you're playing yeah he would
say if you're good you get away with
more right yeah jimmy well jimmy said
yeah i i don't want to
don't don't don't don't he said i'm not
don't talk about fear fear says
everybody gets the same thing
jesse every just says everybody gets
what they deserve if your ass is out
here and you're not making a whole lot
of plays and i got any kind of problem
by
get on out of here yeah but if you make
plays out the plays out the plays have
something we run into a little hiccup we
can work through that yeah
no matter what the hiccup is we can work
through it but my question is like
he sees a talent but there's also
something that he sees
in you and that's like how to coach you
and how to bring out the best of you so
i do you think early on he understood
you can't really tell michael what to do
right jimmy's a psychologist exactly
yeah so tell me tell me when you start
to realize like oh my god he knows go go
go go go go you you hitting yellow on
here cause i'm gonna tell you something
right i was a freshman when i came in my
freshman year we had just lost two of
the top receivers in college football
eda brown and stanley shakespeare and i
was just a freshman i'm sitting there
watching film
watching film and dude jimmy walks by
that psychology part that he walks by
and he sees me enough studying and this
afternoon went through all the fights
and everything and he sees he's been
there studying and studying and studying
and he said hey
he's hey
what's up coach
he said you read the paper
everybody's wondering
what are we going to do now that eddie
brown is shakespeare's song
what are we going to do
yeah he said hey son
wait that show to michael irvin
hmm don't let me down
i should what i'll rest all i need him
oh dawg i put i put on a 50 pound weight
vents go run saving the flights of
stairs all day that's all i was thinking
about well i'ma show them boy i'm sure
but that he knew he knew that he knew
stuff like just little things like that
to push you you know what i mean and
make bring the best out of you he was
great at it because there's certain
coaches that might see you and they
might coach you a different way and then
you guys just have animosity be fighting
right but you wanted to walk through a
wall
right with jimmy and he did it with
charles hayley he did it with charles
hey same thing charles hayden talked
about all the time he said when he went
when he got there that we got charles
haley from san fran because you know
chucky charles had supposedly you know
stood on top of the head coach's car and
just took out the third leg he has and
just watered it down yeah yeah yeah
longest third leg on the cowboys
third
i'm sorry enough for hell this should
not be coming over there i don't want to
be man i'm just saying old story
so so chuck came over to the and then
jimmy knew how to and jimmy knew it
right jimmy went at chuck one time um on
i went yelled they went at him and chuck
was he went in a tank he went in the
tank
and coach said hey
come to my office and he talked to him
about it and coach and jimmy and charles
said coach you know i just you know i
just
it just bothers me when you when it's
like that and call that coach said no
problem okay i said he said that's how
you work that's what i work with he says
i can work with that he said i'll pull
you aside if you need be i don't i don't
mind he said i'm glad you're telling me
this
it means something to a man yeah and he
says from that point charles said we
never had any problems because
that was it you're dealing with grown
men that's what makes football such a
great sport you know and in most worlds
in most worlds i tell people most work
most people in order to be the best in
their world
they they you know they're sitting on a
computer or a designer
and in football in order to be the best
you have to go through what a
hand-to-hand man-to-man come back it's
not just about skill it's also about
will since it's another man i gotta look
in another man's soul who wants to take
care of his family who wants to feed his
wife and kids and say i want it more
than you you know what i'm saying so so
it's not just about my skill it's also
about my will and having a coach that
knows how to tinker with your mind yeah
to make sure your will is right mm-hmm
it's it's making sense basically
because it is it is tricky like you want
there's certain people that can make you
want to give everything for right right
right right right and they just have to
be able to like find that trigger how
right and how do they do it and that's
interesting that he was able to do it
and he was able to do it differently for
you than necessarily with for chuck and
then
as a leader of a team too
now i had to find that with the players
there's a dude
i wanted but he's a defensive back this
dude was a
physical freak of an athlete
and i mean he would be killing it in
practice and then we get in the game and
different things happen and so i'm like
man i gotta figure this out man let's go
and everybody's yelling let's go let's
go let's go and it never really got to
anything so i said okay this is what i
gotta do i said i'm gonna have to spend
some time i'm gonna take some time
i get in my car
i go
i go over to his house
i go to his house i said okay that's
what i'm doing i go to this house i say
hey man what's up dog i said man i'm i'm
in the neighborhood man he said yeah
myself stop by and have a drink which
he's already come over i went by dude he
had his little daughter mm-hmm
it's called a pam in his hand
when i got to the door saying man come
on here might make baby
we got something to eat a drink never
put down the pain right
then when he got ready to walk me to the
car after we know hey and everything
while we're caught in there preparing
all right see you later pam we're
playing with the man i got in the car so
i got this joker now yeah i got him i
got him see in order to lead on me
you got to know what he cares about what
makes the man mm-hmm what makes the man
now the next time we get in the game
and he and he and he wasn't doing well
everybody
yelling at him and and he's he's really
taking it he's taking
i just walked by him i said hey man
that's hey
that's the best you can get pam that's
what you deserve
i walked off oh this was a whole new
moment
i'm talking about you dude we're killing
everybody
[Music]
i just picked up pam i said hey man
pam i'm gonna need you man this is the
best you gotta give her you're gonna be
able to take care of playing like jingle
bells
whoa whole new man come out you gotta
know what pulls a man you know what i
mean like me if you just say it take
care of hey man all you had to do was
say
i thought you said you were going to
take care of your mom you think you
could take care of home with this effort
oh yeah they got a whole nother effort a
whole nother effort what makes that man
tick as a great leader if you are a
great leader
you gotta leave that's why i always tell
people don't be so quick to want to get
in the leadership role because you see
it as a position of dominance and
dominion over people a real leader's
real leadership is not about dominion
over it's about servitude you got to
serve every you got to get the best out
of everybody
and boston people just don't do it and
especially today
especially today and you can't just boss
people any kind of way and think there's
no repercussions
you